bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette édition
de fin de semaine de votre journal
aujourd'hui vendredi 8 juillet je reçois
michel laugier bonsoir bonsoir
le président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin qui va nous accompagner au cours
de la prochaine demi heure nous
parlerons du bilan de l'année des
perspectives aussi pour l'agglomération
et puis bien sûr nous reviendrons sur
l'actualité dans ce journal est
notamment sur le bilan de l'expérience à
plateaux ont mené sur le secteur à paris
saclay depuis deux ans de nombreux
partenaires l'initiative de cette
opération là parmi lesquels la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie à versailles
yvelines saint quentin en yvelines ou
encore psa peugeot citroën leur objectif
générer de la croissance accroître leur
chiffre d'affaires et créer des emplois
depuis août 2015 les loyers sont
encadrés à paris la mesure s'étend
maintenant à l'ensemble de l'île de
france nous verrons comment réagissent
les communes les propriétaires et bien
sûr elle est locataire de notre
département et puis 1723 mètres carrés
répartis sur trois niveaux à la maison
de l'étudiant ouvre ses portes à
guyancourt elle vient compléter le
campus de l'ulb est ce qu visite guidée
au cours de cette édition
on commence donc par de l économie mardi
sur le site du synchrotron soleil s'est
refermée deux ans de travail mené dans
le cadre du réseau plato paris-saclay
les 74 des dirigeants de pme les douze
cadres coach des grandes entreprises
membres du réseau était présent avec
l'ensemble des acteurs impliqués ils ont
fait le point sur leur capacité à
travailler en synergie expliqué assurant
jeu camille lambert deux ans au service
des entrepreneurs c'est l'objectif du
réseau plato un programme originaire de
belgique
introduit en france dans les années 90
le 5 juillet le plateau paris-saclay
2014 2016 a dressé son bilan au
synchrotron soleil 74 pme du territoire
ont pu profiter des conseils de coachs
cadres de grandes entreprises autour de
la table ce ne sont que des dirigeants
d'entreprise
ce qui est intéressant pour eux c'est
d'utiliser l'expérience et de faire
partager leur expérience aux autres
membres du groupe
ça leur a permis vraiment de prendre de
la hauteur par rapport à leur quotidien
et de prendre des décisions qui les ont
aidés à faire croître et leur chiffre
d'affaires en général et notamment au
niveau humain pour certains par beaucoup
de dirigeants embaucher un dispositif
mis en place en partenariat avec les
chambres de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles yvelines et de l'essonne
rompre l isolement devenir plus
compétitifs et managez une équipe
autant de problématiques abordées durant
les réunions une fois par mois on se
pose des questions qu'on ne se posait
pas ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a
des regards qui sont pas ceux que l'on
aurait on est sensibilisé à des sujets
qu'on n'a pas appris à l'école en ce qui
me concerne j'ai une formation
scientifique j'ai pas après tous ces
sujets rhc la pression de terrain c'est
aussi une façon de faire partie du thé
du tissu économique local de se
rapprocher des autres entreprises
pour clore cette session les dirigeants
ont été invités à peindre un tableau
pour illustrer leur expérience à l'issue
de ce plateau paris-saclay 86% des chefs
d'entreprise prévoient de recruter dans
les deux ans coût de l'adhésion de 1500
euros pour un plateau territoriales en
france 1500 pme et pmi ont déjà investi
dans ce programme
michel laugier présidente 50-1 51 kg est
un acteur du réseau plato de
paris-saclay on peut citer aussi la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie
versailles yvelines ou encore des
entreprises psa peugeot citroën bien
d'autres le bilan que vous en faites de
cette expérience
écoutez je trouve que c'est un bilan
très positif puisque 100 % des
entreprises et qui ont participé se sont
dites satisfaites
moi ce qui me réjouit aussi c'est que
nous sommes quand même l'initiative
puisque on s'est développé avec paris
saclay mais initialement nous avions
créé sur le territoire de saint quentin
là avec cette extension sur paris saclay
une vingtaine
on ne sert deux entreprises de notre
territoire ont bien sûr participé à
cette belle cette belle organisation
j'allais dire qui permet finalement aux
pme de se rencontrer parce que c'est
vrai si nous avons de grandes
entreprises sur notre territoire nos
cibles de nombreuses pme et c'est celle
ci qu'il faut aider donc là ça permet
quand même d'avoir du coaching ça nous
permet surtout de se rencontrer et
peut-être de faire naître de nouveaux
projets qui devraient sûrement pas vu le
jour si chacun était resté dans son coin
l'enjeu de paris saclay est important
pas uniquement pour ce territoire mais
pour un enjeu national et même
international pour devenir une place
économique et de développement pour les
entreprises important
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération il trouve justement
toute sa place est à la on l'a vu avec
cet exemple mais est un véritable moteur
pour paris saclay alors il nous sommes
un moteur puisque nous ne sommes pas à
l'étape des promesses mais étape de la
concrétisation 50 à 6 du réel saint
quentin c'est le deuxième pôle
économique après la défense dont je dire
aujourd'hui nous ne sait vraiment du
concret et ses poumons c'est plutôt nous
qui apportons notre expérience à saclay
saclay qui commence à se développer mais
surtout en direction des grandes des
grandes écoles dans direction de
l'université à nous nous avons les deux
nous avons l'université et le monde
économique et je pense que l'on va
pouvoir aussi apporter notre
savoir-faire du côté de paris saclay
peut-être juste une parenthèse on part
un petit peu plus loin mais il ya eu la
sortie de il va y avoir la sortie de
l'angleterre après ce fameux bric cité
et le vote au royaume-uni valérie
pécresse qui souhaite que justement ces
entrepreneurs vient de s'installer un
petit peu dans la région ile de france a
une carte à jouer aussi pour 50 en ligne
et bien sûr puisque dans la région et de
france ont parlé des grands pôles
économiques et 50e ont fait partie donc
je pense moi aussi que les mesures qui
seront prises aussi bien par le
gouvernement que par la région ile de
france seront forcément bénéficiaires à
5 ans très vite puisque nous sommes
devenus d'un territoire indispensable
aujourd'hui à l'écho des françaises on
va parler des projets du bilan de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aussi pour
cette année dans un instant auparavant
un mot encore sur l'actualité c'est
désormais officiel l'encadrement des
loyers va se faire aussi dans
l'intégralité de l'île de france cela
concernait paris les i
eux aussi vont devoir s'y plier nicolas
landry locataire d'un côté et
propriétaire de l'autre la confédération
nationale du logement des yvelines
accompagne locataires dans leurs
démarches
alors que l'union nationale des
propriétaires immobilier 78 conseil les
investisseurs chacun campe sur ses
positions notamment sur l'encadrement
des loyers
parce que beaucoup plus grave c'est pour
les nouveaux investisseurs
parce que les nouveaux investisseurs
aujourd'hui vont décourager à entrer
dans des dispositifs locatifs et nous ce
que l'on rencontre aujourd'hui au niveau
de notre association des yvelines c'est
que on a un certain nombre de
propriétaires qui ont décidé de ne plus
louer dès l'instant que leur appartement
est libre alors ce dispositif sur le
principe mais on est d'accord faut
limiter les loyers ils sont beaucoup
trop élevés en france ça c'est clair
maintenant
le dispositif si nous nous ce qui se
fait pas globalement instauré à paris
cet instrument devrait être étendu dans
certaines communes du département des
yvelines
son principe fixée à un loyer maximum
bailleurs pour limiter les excès parmi
les villes concernées voisins le
bretonneux avec 73 % de propriétaires et
11 % de locataires c'est bien afin de
faire plaisir aux locataires c'est une
bonne chose mais en même temps la
crainte qu'on peut avoir c'est peut-être
par rapport aux investisseurs il
faudrait pas que ça décourage justement
des personnes d'acheter des biens pour
les louer ensuite s'ils n'ont pas la
maîtrise sur leur loyer une bataille de
chiffres règne entre les représentants
pour la confédération nationale du
logement des yvelines
les loyers ont augmenté de plus de 30 %
entre 2004 et 2014
même sur saint cyr l'école où on est par
exemple ans une petite commune j'étais
en train de regarder les agences 1 c
c'est de l'ordre entre 1000 et 1200
euros par mois pour 1 pour 1 68 corps
est-à-dire un petit f3 si les loyers
sont chers c'est parce qu'il ya des
manques de logements les propriétaires
doute de la sincérité de ces données ils
possèdent leur propre diagnostic avec
comme conséquence une autre vision de la
politique du logement aujourd'hui
on regarde vraiment sur les yvelines
légère baisse de l'ordre de 1%
donc pourquoi encadrer des loyers qui
sont en train de baisser
les premiers résultats des études sur
l'efficacité de l'encadrement des loyers
parisiens sont attendus le jeudi 15
juillet date de restitution des
conclusions de l' agence départementale
d'information sur le logement
michel laugier rapidement sur cette
question d'encadrement des loyers vous
faites partie des élus qui sont
satisfaits écoutez je suis partie des
élus surtout qu'ils ne sont pas au
courant parce que c'est bien de de
mettre en place une mesure à condition
déjà qu'ils aient une concertation avec
les élus
là le gouvernement souhaite étendre une
expérimentation sur paris on attend
encore les conclusions sont attendues
pour la vertu est alors que on voit déjà
les tendres en plus on veut l'étendre
sur les communes de saint quentin en
yvelines où finalement le locatif privé
et est une vraiment une denrée rare
justement c'est ce qui nous manque sur
notre territoire puisqu'aujourd'hui nous
avons surtout des logements sociaux dans
dans des proportions différentes entre
les villes et surtout nous avons beau
nous avons un parc privé important ça
irait qui ici les habitants se devenir
propriétaire voilà donc il nous manque
justement cette partie où le
gouvernement voudrait que ce soit
encadré
donc voilà donc géré ça n'est pas très
cohérent ce bonne idée notamment sur le
territoire de 50 alors parlons de ce
territoire de saint quentin justement il
ya un projet important c'est le projet
de territoire c'est son nom est une
vision stratégique à court moyen et long
terme ça va consister en quoi sachant
que ça débute tout juste avec une
participation des habitants de 50 ans on
expliquera les modalités tout à l'heure
mais dans l'est dans les grandes lignes
ça consiste en quoi
dans le grand de ligne c'est de dire
aujourd'hui nous avons un nouveau
territoire puisque nous sommes passés
deux à douze communes donc aujourd'hui
c'est de bâtir notre projet pour ses
douze communes pour les dix ou vingt ans
à venir
ce qu'on soit cohérent dans notre vision
du l'urbanisme qu'on soit cohérent dans
l'accompagnement de la vie associative
qu'en soient cohérents dans notre
politique sportive culturelle sociale
dans l'accompagnement aussi qu'on peut
avoir dans la politique de la ville
voilà c'est définir tout ça alors bien
sûr les élus à la fin prendre leurs
responsabilités et moi je souhaite que
un certain nombre de partenaires soient
associés et donc c'était cette grande
démarche qui va être entreprise au délà
dès la rentrée mais qui commence déjà
pendant l'été puisque ans sollicite déjà
les habitants à travers des envois de
photos alors on joue petit peu avec les
mots ce qui jadis et le néo non ce qui
me plaît ce qui me plaît pas voilà donc
on demande aux gens les sollicitent à
travers les réseaux sociaux dont vous
aurez tout ça sur le site internet de
l'agglomération mais en tout cas nous ce
qu'on veut c'est bien connaître aussi un
petit peu ce que pensent les habitants
ce que pense bien sûr aussi les chefs
d'entreprises qui sont installés sont
territoire ce que pense aussi les
universitaires voilà on fait partie d'un
beau territoire qui est très varié bien
aujourd'hui on souhaite à de lui donner
encore plus de cohérence
ça veut dire qu ensuite sur un
calendrier avec b une fois que ce sera
adopté avec voo tv présenté mais il y
aura un calendrier avec démesure des
réalisations concrètes sur à des bilans
d'étape puisqu'on parle aussi d'un
projet sur le long terme ça des vies
bien sûr c'est vrai que appartements ont
défini notre projet il sera lancé et par
contre une fois qui sera annoncée faute
rossi que on mettre les moyens qu'il
faut avec 6 des priorités émergent qui
ne sont pas celles que nous avons
aujourd'hui à bien va falloir aussi que
l'on corrige ses visions là donc
aujourd'hui on souhaite vraiment s'axer
sur les prochaines années et avoir une
vision sur du moyen
voire du long terme et donc pour débuter
ce sont les habitants notamment qui sont
sollicités vous l'avez mentionné avec
les réseaux sociaux ce hashtag ce qui
demain notamment pour ce qui me plaît ce
qui ne plaît pas effectivement tout est
expliqué sur le site de l'agglomération
vous pouvez participer via les réseaux
sociaux ou via une adresse mail pasty
vidéo photo est ce qui s qui y demain à
la base est-ce qu'ils y justement point
fr voilà pour pouvoir et y participer le
changement cette année ç'a aussi été
principalement l'arrivée de ces
nouvelles communes on passe de 7 à 12
communes au sein de saint quentin en
yvelines
le bilan que vous en faites de l'arrivée
de ces communes le bilan que nous en
faisons déjà c'est que ces communes
voulez nous rejoindre à tout on pourrait
mentionner coignières où c'était un
petit peu plus compliqué c'est peut-être
là dedans l'ancien maire de coignières
lui peut-être n'était pas favorable en
tout cas le maire actuel l'événement et
il est pleinement investi en plus dans
la délégation que je lui ai donné au
niveau des hauts niveaux des sports ont
déjà ces communes voulez nous rejoindre
bon maintenant il ya un travail
important qui doit être fait encore on
est arrivé au bout de cette intégration
on a toujours un budget à double vitesse
donc parce que c'est pas d'un coup de
baguette magique ce pas parce que la loi
dit qu'au 1er janvier il faut qu'on soit
dans une intercommunalité que tous les
problèmes sont réglés
d'ailleurs la loi nous laisse jusqu'à la
fin de l'année 2007 pour régler toutes
les intégrations à 1017 de 2017 pardon
s'cusez moi jusqu'à 2017 par contre nous
nous voulons franchement déjà aboutir
dès la fin de l'année 2016 parce que
pour nous il est temps que les choses
soient bien claires pour tout le monde
sur les compétences alors ça on fait de
grandes avancées nous avons déjà défini
le cadre des compétences ce qui était
indispensable et là bas nous l'avons
fait à l'unanimité
on voyait bien que les choses avancent
bien à douz donc les 12 communes
participent bien sûr à ce travail
le préfet vient de publier son d'arrêter
donc lab dès la rentrée prochaine nous
allons travailler le périmètre de ses
compétences on a pris certaines
compétences la culture le sport et ses
rames étant à l'intérieur et alors qu'on
définisse la totalité du périmètre de
ses compétences c'est un travail
fastidieux c'est un travail important
on a déjà bien bien avancé également
même sur ce sujet là donc il restera
ensuite à bien définir les choses pour
que tout soit prêt en fin d'année vous
parliez du vote à l'unanimité
peut-on même évoqué quelques sujets qui
fâchent parce que les discours des
communes dites d'opposition pour
simplifier les choses
les communes qui sont deux majorités de
gauche et critique certaines prises de
décision alors on va pas rentrer dans le
coeur de tous les dossiers il faudrait
beaucoup plus que qu'une demi heure
d'émission mais il ya les questions
d'aménagement que ce soit quartier des
bécanes la question d'aménagement de
guyancourt les questions de culture
enfin globalement on sent que les une
certaine tension qui existe aujourd'hui
entre la nouvelle majorité déjà installé
depuis quelques temps maintenant et puis
les anciennes que les anciennes communes
anciennement majoritaire alors il ya
justement c'est peut-être ça c'est parce
que l'essentiel en majorité avec eux il
faut faire aussi la l'effort de de voir
qu on n'est plus dans la même
organisation
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose il ya aussi des postures il faut
toujours se méfier des postures c'est
bien d'avoir certaines attitudes en
conférence de presse dans des camps dans
des communiqués dans des pétitions je
dire après ce qui compte pour moi c'est
le travail qui est fait et quand on doit
travailler individuellement les choses
se passent très bien sur les bécanes je
dire vous allez voir que nous allons
aboutir sans aucun problème au projet et
au démarrage de la zac des a des cannes
et les sujets les plus importants sont
votés à l'unanimité
on nous avons voté par exemple lors du
dernier conseil le pacte financier
impact financier qui existait sur les
collines historique et qu'aujourd'hui
est étendue aux 12
ça a été voté à l'unanimité vous voyez
bien que hier soit par exemple j'avais
un bureau le bureau de l'agglomération
sur 30 délibération 30 délibérations ont
été prises à l'unanimité et le concerne
toutes les communes et tous les secteurs
ce soit l'aménagement d'environnement
les travaux la culture tout a été pris
le nez mythe et donc ya les discours et
après il ya les actes et moi je préfère
être jugé sur mes actes que sur des
discours et des postures vous parler du
budget tout à l'heure la priorité c'est
de continuer le désendettement aussi de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça c'est une
mission importante et il ya eu cette
note de gestion de standard and poor's
qu'on compte précise plus qu'on ne
présente plus cette note de référence à
long terme qui est passé alors deux
a+ à à moins c'est ce qui est une
meilleure note puisque c'est un double à
et puis celle à court terme qui est
relevé à à -1 plus contre à moins un
voilà on est vraiment dans la subtilité
mais en tout cas il ya une amélioration
7 il faut souligner wynigen amélioration
et moi c'est toujours plus agréable de
se faire juger par des personnes
extérieures indépendante et qui ont
quand même un point important puisque ça
nous permet à près de pouvoir emprunter
auprès des banques dont je dire
aujourd'hui quand une somme jugée par
des agences de notation et que nous
avons notre en progression ce qu'il faut
rappeler c'est le contexte quand même
parce que nous depuis deux ans nous
avons pris des décisions importantes
nous avons eu 10 millions en moins de
l'état et qui amène la dotation de la
ville et qu'il a fallu trouver dont 10
millions en moins de l'état et
aujourd'hui nous avons restructuré aussi
notre organisation administrative nous
avons pris des décisions importantes
nous avons réduit
bien sûr notre train de vie est
aujourd'hui bien haut ce qu'on voit
c'est que tous ces efforts là avec des
projections sur les années à venir bien
font que les agences de notation estime
que le travail de saint quentin est un
très bon travail financière l'économie
vous mettez l'accent sur cette donnée
alors ça se traduit aussi et bien par
des soirées événementielles repense à la
soirée des entrepreneurs qui s'est
déroulé cette année et puis pour parler
un peu de la ddt la rentrée il ya aussi
cette question d'incubateur ski cube
pouvait nous en servions oui mais tout
simplement enfin il n'y a pas que un
incubateur nous allons réunir dans un
même ensemble la maison de l'entreprise
un lieu aussi où les patrons
d'entreprises où les collaborateurs
doute russe pour en venir aussi
travailler puis aussi un incubateur et
je crois que ce soit le premier organisé
par une collectivité dans le département
des yvelines tout du coin et wap et là
dessus c'est quelque chose qui va se
mettre en place à l'automne et avec
aussi quelque chose de très emblématique
puisque nous avons souhaité avoir un
bâtiment qu'ils soient vus je rappelle
que jusqu'à présent la maison de
l'entreprise même avec un gps vous
n'arrivez pas à trouver
donc là cette fois c'est visible on la
verra puisque ça sera sur le rond-point
dsi vide
entre guyancourt et montigny sur la
commune de vue en cours est donc là bas
ce sera la partie visible de l'action
que l'on souhaite mener aujourd'hui en
direction du monde économique
il y avait beaucoup d'action qui a été
menée par le passé mais beaucoup
d'actions qui ne produisait pas grand
chose pour nous aujourd'hui on veut
réduire ses actions mais être beaucoup
plus efficace et c'est le travail que
nous faisons avec les chefs
d'entreprises avec les pme surtout parce
qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de pme ont parlé
tout à l'heure de l'opération plateau et
bien donc n'a aujourd'hui nous
souhaitons encore te plus proche nous du
monde économique
et puis surtout nous continuons cas même
à faciliter leur implantation il ya
beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui qui se
trame sur le secteur de saint quentin en
yvelines bien nous allons faciliter à
travers les pays existants mais avec le
paie lui demain à partir de début de
l'été prochaine donc on va encore
faciliter l'arrivée de nouvelles
entreprises
et moi je suis vraiment très très
heureux de voir que les investisseurs
sont toujours là viennent toujours taper
à la porte de saint quentin en yvelines
aussi bien pour construire du logement
que pour attirer de nouvelles
entreprises
et quand de grands noms sont présents
sur le territoire et surtout quand
certains de ses gros nom change de
locaux des restes sur le territoire moi
je suis plutôt fier un dernier mot
concernant l'actualité vous parler de
cette maison pour les entrepreneurs il
ya aussi la maison de l'étudiant qui a
ouvert ses portes maison l'étudiant qui
sera officiellement inauguré à la
rentrée néanmoins nous vous proposons
dès à présent une petite visite guidée
une salle pour les arts plastiques une
pour l'informatique ou une autre pour
les chorales la région a misé sur le
confort et le développement artistique
avec cette nouvelle maison de l'étudiant
plus de huit millions d'euros ont été
investis
le terrain a été fournie par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et la ville de guyancourt
si l'aménagement de cet espace de 1732
mètre carré n'est pas encore terminée
les étudiants peuvent déjà en profiter
je trouve ça vraiment très jolie fin
c'est tout nouveau c'est bien et récits
très moderne fin pour nous les jeunes je
pense que vraiment ça peut être très
très cool sens
bâtiment je sais pas encore tout ce
qu'il contient mais en tout cas ce qui
est des cool c'est que il sent le bois
donc ça c'est plutôt agréable et
j'espère qu'il est qu'il a des bonnes
normes écologiques et c'est cool quoi
les associations elles aussi sont ravis
de l'ouverture des locaux elle imagine
déjà se développer les services de
l'université pourront travailler en
partenariat avec elle aussi bien pour
l'accès à l'emploi que pour la
prévention médicale ou bienvenue en
visibilité auprès des étudiants qui
savent enfin qu'il existe un service
médical parce qu'ils nous voient
puis ils sont venus nous rencontrer
potentiellement chaque jour et en dames
en indycar locales ont convoqué c'est
l'espace consultation et information qui
est véritablement un lieu cosy et
professionnels ou les étudiants pourront
venir chercher des informations sur les
stages et la professionnalisation
l'ouverture officielle de la maison de
l'étudiant aura lieu le 22 septembre en
présence notamment de valérie pécresse
présidente de la région ile de france
le guichet unique d'inscription sera lui
ouvert dès le début du mois cette maison
de l'étudiant financé par la région mais
sur un terrain de l'agglomération et et
de guyancourt on leur précise élément
important pour le développement le
rayonnement de l'université de
versailles saint quentin le campus
c'était encore un peu plus bien sûr je
crois que on ne peut qu'être satisfait
de ce qui se passe au niveau nous de
notre université de versailles saint
quentin et justement j'ai travaillé hier
avec le président et nous évoquions tous
et tous ces sujets alors c'est vrai que
la maison de l'étudiant va apporter un
plus il ya des actions que des bd déjà
mais c'est vrai qu'on avait un petit peu
de mal à les lire c'est un petit peu
comme tout à l'heure sur le monde
économique donc il faut quelque chose
qui rassemble tous qu'ils soient un
guichet unique et c'est un petit peu ce
qui se passe là donc les étudiants
pourront trouver
là aujourd'hui à toute réponse à leur
question que ce soit sur leur parcours
ce soit sur les activités annexes qui
peuvent avoir que ce soit aussi sur le
logement jouera bien qu'à même qu'on a
construit de très nombreux logements
illicites depuis voilà et depuis on fait
de très gros efforts voilà donc après il
faut quand même structure et parce que
nous avons quinze mille étudiants qui
sont aujourd'hui sur notre territoire
et bien sûr il faut qu'il soit le
intégrée de la meilleure des façons
michel laugier présente cinquante
invités de ce journal de fin de semaine
et vous en avez l'habitude si vous nous
suivez le vendredi nous revenons un
petit peu sur sur l'actualité très
rapidement trois points d'actualité de
cette semaine aussi bien national qu'au
niveau local la disparition de michel
rocard tout d'abord l'ancien premier
ministre socialiste est aussi une figure
politique du département des yvelines ya
une certaine unanimité autour de son
action oui cela j'ai toujours aimé son
état d'esprit est vraiment quelqu'un
aussi qu'ils savaient assurer et assumer
ses propos pie ix
là je me souviens qu'à même l'un dont
j'étais journaliste à votre place
d'avoir reçu et vu plusieurs fois michel
rocard et c'était quelqu'un de vraiment
un sujet très intéressant pour
journalistes parce qu'il est pouvait
répondre à toutes les questions avec des
idées 4,6 maire de conflans députés
sénateurs aussi et des yvelines je leur
précise et puis l'open de golf qui s'est
achevée c'était dimanche dernier il ya
tout juste cinq jours
nous sommes le vendredi cet open de golf
est une réussite dans l'optique de
l'accueil de la ryder cup ce sera en
2018 et un nouveau record de
fréquentation battu un record de
fréquentation datura centimes il
je pense qu'on le doit plusieurs
facteurs la présence de mcilroy déjà
donc en compte vous avez un champion
aussi prestigieux satire du monde
deuxièmement parce que c'était aussi la
100e édition de l'open de france
et troisièmement parce que c'était la
première sortie officielle du nouveau
parcours de l'albatros dans sa
configuration ryder cup
je pense que vu l'affluence vu l'eau si
la réaction des golfeurs professionnels
on est vraiment prêt là pour 2018 et on
a hâte d'y être et on reste dans le
sport avec l'euro il ya plein d'autres
sujets pour vous faire réagir sur
l'actualité mais l'euro forcément c'est
important il ya une retransmission dans
votre commune la commune de montigny le
bretonneux
vous me disiez tout à l'heure quelque
chose c'était d'ailleurs plutôt bien
passé l'envoi des images d'une
précédente retransmission de deux
matches la finale ce sera portugal
france forcément votre pronostic
la france quel score ont fouillé un peu
plus un peu plus le jeu moi je vois bien
3,3 pour le problème pendant ces trois
réalisations et buteur griezmann
forcément alors grise badges ou aussi un
but de payet et un but de payet très
bien pour se remettre un petit peu aussi
en confiance et puis là vous voyez des
images c'était hier soir justement du
côté de saint germain en laye avec comme
partout dans le département et comme
partout en france beaucoup d'animations
et de joie après la victoire enfin face
à l'allemagne dans une compétition
d'envergure merci michel boyer je peux
juste dire qu'il y aura bien sûr aussi
une fan zone dimanche soir au gymnase de
pierre de coubertin montini pour que
tous les aînés montagne viennent
encourager l'équipe de france et
peut-être aussi quelques semaines
l'équipe du portugal
et puis pour ceux qui n'y seront pas
rendez vous lundi pour le journal pour
voir toutes les images et les réactions
après la victoire vous nous l'avait
pronostiqué de la france merci michel
laugier c'est la fin de cette édition
tout de suite le 7-8 week end vos idées
sorties et loisirs le journal revient
lundi avec floriane parfait